let's bring in mike Mayock the Raiders
GM let me start with the poll question
Mike who do you think will draft Cuyler
Murray it's early I thought I'm gonna
get you on that your poll question
really okay am I gonna stand there was a
day you were subtle I just always that
way okay can I talk to the analyst mike
Mayock for a moment as opposed to the
BGM Mike may I okay
have you learned to lie I'm not a really
good liar like my kids say I mean the
end of the at the end of the day Kyler
Murray is just intriguing it's become
such a quarterback driven League it
seems like every year when I was an
analyst I felt like there were three or
four quarterbacks that probably should
have been mid to late first rounders for
True Value and they always got pushed up
and kind of into the top 10 or top 5 and
I think it happens every year and I
think we're in the midst of I mean at
this point of the year in March you know
I think the quarterback thing becomes
more and more conversation and caller
Murray has got special talent Haskins
has special talent from Ohio State kid
from Mizzou has special talent so yeah I
think all those guys are very intriguing
should we care about height or lack
thereof at that position I think we're
getting to the point you know drew Brees
was always kind of a standard bearer but
Russell Wilson and you know you start
watching the way the game has changed
we're getting more and more the spread
style offense from the colleges and I
think you know you watch the film a
collar Murray the kids got a big arm the
ball hops out of his hand he seems to
find passing lanes not many balls get
knocked down so you'll always have some
concern about that but I think there are
other variables that come into play for
him
you and John did not go to Cuyler
Murray's pro day what was the reason for
that John and I were a little bit busy
with free agency okay
does the pro day matter that much to you
two coaches two GM's I think for four
quarterbacks I think you have to see
them live it doesn't have to be a pro
day I think you have to see him throw
the ball live it can certainly be during
a season it can be at a lot of different
places but it's the one position where I
think you can watch all the tape in the
world but you also have to at least see
the ball live out of his hand I've
always believed that and I think I
always will
we're talking to mike Mayock the Oakland
Raiders GM joining us Dan Patrick show
it's still tough to say that Mike I mean
I'm proud I'm happy for you but it's
Mike may like I'm so you say mike Mayock
at the NFL Network take me through the
Antonio Brown trade can you can you take
give me some of the you know backroom
dealings or the gory details here of how
did you pull this off and you pulled off
a great deal well I mean k-kevin Kolbert
the GM from the Steelers has been a
friend for 18 years and you know with he
and I had talked for a few weeks prior
to the trade and and I told him we had
no interest in trading one of our
first-round picks and John and I have
been unified on that front and so I kept
saying we're not interested we're not
interested we're not interested and then
the Buffalo thing fell through that
Friday and they reached out one of their
guys reached out to John and John
reached out to me and I called Kevin and
Kevin said would you would you trade
your two and I said no but you know we
might trade our three I think we'd go
with our three and long story short we
came to an agreement on a three and a
five and the hard part started after
that to be honest with you I mean the
hard part was it was contingent upon
getting a be signed to a new deal and he
had certain goals and parameters and we
had certain goals and parameters the
deal was on and off two or three
different times I mean I went to bed
Friday night that deal was off and we
got up Saturday morning and to Drew
Rosenhaus is credit he knows how to put
a deal together I mean he know he's he's
tenacious and you know we went back and
forth I can't tell you how many times
and we moved a little may moved a little
and ultimately Antonio Brown became a
rare yeah I'm always curious about that
that you know the best deal you can make
sometimes is when you can walk away from
a deal or you give the impression I can
walk away from this deal was that part
of the strategy I think you've always
got to be willing to walk away from a
deal and and we went into it and there
was the bottom line is again John and I
were unified on those three first-round
picks so as intriguing as a B was we
were trying to build this team a certain
way but when he became available at a
different level it was kind of like
listen you know we can change how we
practice we can change what we look like
on Sunday we can change how teams have
to defend us and for a three and a five
at that point we were ready to say okay
it looks like free agencies got to
change for us and I mean the funniest
part was I barely have been out of this
building and our owner Mark Davis asked
John and I to come to Las Vegas for it
for an event that Friday and so we took
our wives if we barely saw our wives it
was you know we as John said the press
comes who were basically dating Drew
Rosenhaus and Antonio Brown that night
on the phone and trying to make things
happen so it was pretty cool and and
ultimately it worked out are you
rebuilding I'm not sure how to define
what the Raiders are doing after you
trade khalil Mac and you trade Amari
Cooper and then you bring in a B look I
wasn't here last year so I can't speak
for that what I do know is we were four
and twelve we added four really
important starting players to our team
this and we haven't even talked about
Trent Brown who's 25 years old
and we think one of the dominating
ascending linemen in this league Tyrell
Williams who played for our division
rival Chargers we're going to pair him
with a B LaMarcus Joyner our nickel
slash safety who we think is special and
again all those guys are young so people
look at me and say well you know Antonio
Brown is gonna be 31 years old and I'm
like yeah but dude he travels with the
nutritionist he travels with his trainer
I've never seen a guy that spends more
time trying to make sure that he's going
to play four seven eight nine more years
and I thought the most telling comment
he made in the press conference when he
was asked about goals and ambitions
outside of team goals he said I'd like
to catch Jerry Rice and he believes it
and I love that he believes it so I
don't think his age is contrary to what
we're trying to do as far as building a
young powerful tough football team you
know when you look at personality where
do you stand
i doesn't strike me as Gruden's afraid
of that but you know when you're
bringing in a big personality by Antonio
Brown what concerns if any do you have I
look at the positive side of it first of
all the connection between him and Jon
Gruden was amazing I mean just John's
connects you with players I mean they
want to come play for Chuckie it's
unbelievable
and the two of them giggling like little
kids watching clips of Antonio Brown in
his office after we signed him was just
priceless as far as you know whatever
happened in Pittsburgh I mean you know
that thing fell apart in the last year
and sometimes those things happen I saw
nothing and again I've seen him
practiced and ten or fifteen times in my
duties as a broadcaster and with Trobe
Pennsylvania in in a hundred degree
weather
nobody practices harder it's you know
you can say what you want about who he
is or what he is or you know all I know
is he wants the football and he
practices harder than anybody he's
potentially a Hall of Fame wide receiver
and again he kind of changes what we do
on offense what are you in Gruden talk
about what do you say to each other
I don't know what that means
well when you see him like non foot do
you have any non-football conversations
I mean he's all ball our non football
conversations basically evolve around
other teams football and you know yeah
you think hey what do you think of the
moves with Denver hey what do you got up
with who's the top guy in your tackle
board I'm like coach you know how you
doing man it's good to see it would you
be surprised of Arizona does not end up
with Kotter Murray I have no idea who's
gonna do what and I and I mean that I
mean it took Josh Rosen last year all we
can do is control what we can control
and we've got three picks in the first
round and we better be prepared for all
eight of our picks that that's all I
know
all right final 20 seconds do you think
you could take Gruden take him where you
know in me I know what you mean dad I I
think it would I think if you put us in
a closed environment the only one guy
could get out yeah it'd be pretty
interesting oh I like that I like that I
Congrats on the job and the success so
far it's gonna be a fun ride we
appreciate your time as always Mike hey
Dan thank you good luck
alright that's mike Mayock the Raiders
GM you know I couldn't fool him I
couldn't get him to wait into the put
you didn't give us an answer on the poll
question all of a sudden now he's mr. GM
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you